as guardians of the galaxy I'm excited
for this new rock stars Thor for
guardians the galaxy crossover confirmed
bale villain theory wants it too much
right now but someone might be going on
new rock stars rogue theory channel at
some point very very soon let's watch
this
well connecting rock stars I'm Erik
Bosse thunder or as I like to call it
door for Gore war for more Korg just
drop some major plot details the
guardians of the galaxy are confirmed to
be crossing over with Thor in this next
film which is all painting a very
interesting picture combined with the
details about Christian Bale confirmed
as the Thor villain this may not be
officially called the as guardians of
the galaxy the hype remains real and now
I'm gonna break down all the new things
we now know about Thor 4 spoiler warning
in case you suck and pits to privacy
icon for sponsoring this episode if you
sign up now at privacy calm flashy new
rock stars you can get $5 today to use
on any purchase online recently buddies
all pulled over Ke$ha living his life a
quarter mile at a time to talk about
doing the voice of grewed in the Marvel
films and drop this interesting gem
about the guardians of the galaxy
appearing in the next door though Thor
will also the director talked to me
about how Thor will incorporate some of
the guardians of the galaxy which would
be very interesting nobody is all about
family to you this reveal confirms the
always intended plan after Avengers end
game which ended with Thor joining the
guardians of the galaxy and humorously
feuding with Peter quill Luber who is
the captain now originally guardians of
the galaxy vol 3 was it going to come
out before Thor for probably an intended
release date of May 2020 when Black
Widow is now coming out but then all
that dumb drama and Summer 2018 led to
director James Gunn being temporarily
fired from guardians three band even
worse Delaine nerdy YouTube channels
from having more to break down and hash
tag actors accidentally leaving their
Instagram posts after in game came out
gun broke his social media silence to
confirm that guardians 3 would not be
titled as guardians of the galaxy for
this as a rule Audi crossover and when
Marvel announced its phase 4 lineup
shortly after guardians vol 3 was
nowhere in sight delayed to 2022 were
beyond sometime after
gun wraps his Suicide Squad sequel for
DC coming August 20 2001 expedited
mystery lingering on that base for
horizon was Thor 4 titled the war love
and thunder with the now oscar-winning
Taika Waititi returning to write and
direct wife et cited the Jason Aaron
comic storyline the Mighty Thor which
leads to Jane Foster wielding Mjolnir as
lady Thor suffering from cancer
powering up in Thor motovun reverting
and resetting her chemo it's some real
[ __ ] Christian Bale was announced to be
playing a supporting role later reported
to be alien in otherworldly and recently
Valkyrie actors has a Thompson straight
up revealed that Bale would be playing
the movies villain some familiar faces
some new people into the mix Christian
Bell is gonna play our villain which is
gonna be watch your phrasing around us
now just as an alien otherworldly
villain and a [ __ ] inspired by the Jason
Aaron comic run yeah we're almost
certainly guests humming him down to
gore the god butcher from Jason Aaron
Scott a thunder in original sin
storylines they Creasy the mighty thor
gourd swore to rid the universe of all
deities after these false gods abandoned
his family and their time of need
years later the mere thought of gore
being right causes Thor to drop the
hammer and walk away
leading to Jane Foster later picking it
up some have also been pushed as beta
ray bill but as we saw from that's a car
statue of Bill he's at korbinite with a
horse face and you do not cast a face as
iconic as christian bale's for his voice
along but Vin Diesel confirming a Thor
Guardians crossover opens up other
options for bales villain and the way
love and thunder story could go look
keeping up with content these days talk
if now we have to get it all from these
subscription services about you but wait
10 things at all times you said we only
pay for the content I'm actually
consuming at any given moment
the trick is managing the credit card
numbers that you give these folks they
can turn it off and turn it back on
whenever you need it
well thanks to privacy not Congress
sponsoring this video Rises she lets you
make online purchases using virtual
burner cards for each kind of purchase
instead of your moment or for everything
this protects the Internet and unless
you control the limits on each virtual
card so for example I've set up an
account with privacy I've linked my bank
account and I created a card
specifically for my monthly Netflix
subscription payments privacy will ding
you be really
precision yes someone tries to charge a
car twice or if the charge exceeds the
amount you set for it ha nice try
Netflix I already finished I am NOT okay
with this the only coin I will toss is
for more Witcher no vendor can
overcharge be honest and simple it's
fast it's really just one click they
also offer these different plans there's
a free one that lets you create up to 12
cards a month but also a pro plan where
you can get 36 cards a month and 1% cash
which says an e team's plan for small
businesses there's a privacy Chrome
extension where you can fill out all of
your card info to save time just one
click and all your details are instantly
entered head to icbc.com slash new rock
stars and sign up for an account has a
special treat for my viewers new
customers will automatically get five
dollars to spend on your first purchase
for a time only free derry just go to
privacy calm slash new rock stars and
sign up now Vin Diesel's exact words
were some of the guardians of the galaxy
so to me that sounds like less of a full
team crossover infinitely man work then
an assortment of some of the characters
associated with the Guardians side of
the galaxy and some loose ends from the
Guardians films tying in to the love and
thunder plot one of those loose ends
could be Adam warlock the genetically
perfect space Jesus by Aisha to seek
revenge against the Guardians Adam would
also fit the bill of an alien
otherworldly villain to know these
characters before his Batman days Bale
played the smooth skinned perfectionist
Patrick Bateman and American Psycho
paying him gold and you got yourself a
face Jesus another connection between
the court and the guardians corner to
the cosmos are the elders of the
universe Benicio del Toro as the
collector 10 alerta Vaughn and Jeff
Goldblum as the Grand Master and we
gassed both elders are in rough shape
after some recent events the collector
was a reality stone projection and
infinity war but you know might be dead
or bubbles or something and the Grand
Master was at the mercies of the Sicari
and trash spoke so perhaps bale could
swoop to their aid as their brother the
elder of the universe try crows yeah
there is champion of universally the
master of unarmed combat and seeks new
opportunities to defeat the greatest
fighters from across the galaxy so just
imagine bales screaming himself horse as
he calls that fat Thor for a challenge
and forces the god of thunder to get
back into shape Jake man even fatter
you're unbelievable man you're
unbelievable number of times you're
strolling around in the background but
which guardians of galaxies are these
some men
Diezel referred to well obviously groot
he was in that conversation and diesel
had an interesting description for
groots new form I only have two words
about that character and it is alpha
group so by alpha groots he could be
referring to King Groot an alternate
reality warlord version of group who
never met rocket or join the guardians
it could also mean the inclusion of
groups whole society the florid colossi
from Planet X who are ruled over by the
arbor masters or maybe Diesel's just
reminding the ROC that he's always out
for but too many of the Guardians and
the story gets a bit crowded by familiar
faces
I think Tessa Thompson was referring to
cameos by Groot and maybe Rocket while
the main story of love and thunder will
remain centered around Thor Valkyrie and
Jane as the new Mjolnir wielder after
bale arrives as a villain who rattles
Thor to his core but not before the war
for more Korg dams which Guardians do
you want to cameo in Thor for be sure to
join our official discord server where
we theorize on all the stuff with our
inner circle of supporters access our
discord by becoming a patron of new rock
sirs today at patreon.com fighting star
helmet down below with your thoughts
follow me Eddie a Voss follow new rock
stars and subscribe to directors are
everything marble thanks for watching
bye great video love the information I
am so fascinated to see Christian Bale
working on the direction of tyka ytt
because taiko is very loose on set
according to everyone who's ever worked
with him blows a lot of improv a whole
lot of comedy going on in front of the
camera behind the camera and Christian
Bale is so intense he is known to
constantly stay in character if not in
character at least the voice like you
talked about this point at times
especially during promos from 4-view
Ferrari he's aware he's making a movie
other you like he would always say as
Ken miles he stays in character but if
he was really just under the delusion
that he was only Ken miles he'd probably
drive off set I wonder how Tyco ITT
would work with Christian Bale under the
type of method acting that Bale
specifically goes for I'm just
fascinated to see what it is because
another was a joke you don't want to
cover Christian Bale space I still feel
like Christian Bale will be
down for something like that honestly to
get really lost in the makeup and cover
him up as long as the audience still
knows that's Christian Bale doing the
character I think this could bring a
certain level of weight to the role but
it would also be really cool to see
Christian Bale just really let loose you
know like one thing I've always joked
about is seeing like a Daniel day-lewis
and the Farrelly Brothers movie because
he just can't imagine that ever
happening psych
I would love to see Christian Bale
really give in to a comedy full
heartedly maybe not taking himself as
serious as he usually does I really got
excited and curious when I heard the
casting information just because yeah
this does seem like a strange place for
him to show the casting for these movies
has changed a lot over the years we get
the a-listers now we get caliber actors
and yet Christian Bale was still of an
ilk that I kind of didn't expect to see
in a comic book movie let alone a Marvel
movie very soon I have to imagine that
either he was drawn by the opportunity
to do something new in this arena or
perhaps also yeah the opportunity to
jump in and maybe do some mocap or
something like that especially after
guys like obviously Andy Serkis but Josh
Brolin have really like transcended that
to the point where you know you can tell
who's giving the performance as well as
all the effects like that generally the
gore character sounded the most
interesting in terms of acting chops
because yeah if you've got this personal
background of like the gods didn't help
with my family perish if Christian Bale
is gonna be a villain in any one of
these movies he's got to be a moral
longer esque villain who has a relatable
or a rich story - and not just a good
actor to dress up you know the rare kind
of villains stuff and that's my like
concern if anything I think if you get
Christian Bale as the villain you can
get someone who's very threatening
Michael Weiss you did just one for Jo Jo
rabbit for Best Screenplay I don't agree
with the assertion that thor ragnarok is
only a comedy i think it is absolutely
visually dazzling there are straight-up
shots that just look like paintings it's
gorgeous I think there is dramatic heft
but I think the the main takeaway that
people often have with it is purely
comedy and I don't want this next Thor
to lose the comedy but I think it would
be cool to add a little bit more of that
additional nuance to it especially if
they are bar from the comics would Jane
Foster struggling with cancer there are
some themes here that I
you can really delve with Tycho ITT is
obviously proven he can deal with
heavier subjects if needed there's been
things that Thor has had to deal with
and I could see this villain lining the
loss of asgaard and thor ragnarok and
hen game you see him you know it's fat
or dealing with his alcoholism and then
at the end of the movie he hands off
Asgard to Valkyrie what they were
referencing here in this new rockstars
video is pulling from the comics I can
see them not maybe doing exactly that
but something akin to it as well and I
thought they confirmed whether or not
he's still gonna be fat Thor because if
I don't think so
I wonder be interesting see it and I can
also see it going back I wouldn't mind
it being fat Thor especially under Tycho
ITD's direction I think they could
really have a lot of fun with that some
people did have the complaint that they
thought it was an overdone joke I didn't
see it as solely a joke like it was
really funny here but it wasn't only a
joke maybe they can meet a middle ground
we're still like losing weight maybe
it's not like super obese still in the
show yeah or out though in the movie
he's losing weight that does excite mean
as far as the guardians of the galaxy
it's weird because I have been saying
constantly that for the guardians of
galaxy vol 3
I don't think Thor should be in it
that's been a big topic of discussion so
I'm glad James Gunn verified that he
won't be in it James Gunn has had a
solid trilogy and mine from my
understanding he's always had a three
part trilogy imide he should get the
opportunity to complete his story and I
don't think Thor was ever a part of that
story on the flip side though Guardians
appearing in a Thor movie he is a
different conversation yeah Association
of James Gunn two guardians of the
galaxy is so specific in terms of the
gardens the galaxy solo films but Thor
has this is like Tycho Ortiz the third
director to take on this franchise it's
constantly it shifted directions a
couple times now and it doesn't seem
like Thor 4 supposed to be like this
completes the solo Thor journey that I
feel like having the got a few guardians
in it wouldn't hurt the film at all and
it would be fine yeah and they wouldn't
overtake Thor I feel like having Thor
truly be a massive part of a Guardians
movie might overshadow the Guardians
themselves because he is one of the og
MCU Avengers and yeah having more
characters now that we're on the fourth
Thor movie as opposed to the next
guardians be number three we're so much
more used to more and more character
mixing in and out of that world Thor can
travel through realms and through time
and space that's where it makes a lot of
sense to put these some of the guardians
in any way whoever besides Groot ends up
there say introduce a new iteration of
group in that movie and a Thor fort
might be just a neat little side thing
to that's like the way how thor ragnarok
took advantage of showing a different
side of Hulk maybe they can do something
like that here in Thor 4 with a
different side a group that we haven't
seen yet so I'm excited for this man
Thor 11 Thunder hearing Tycho's back I'm
excited for the Jane Foster lady Thor
version as well all right guys well if
you haven't done so already subscribe to
new rock stars you can subscribe to the
real rejects please click that
notification Bella get notified whenever
got a youtube video up last not least
I'll send this with a mic me through the
valleys down the hills and up to the
trees mister Romney one media just
kidding but seriously a lot of people do
trip over that one man you anticipate
that when you pick the name or do you
kind of kick yourself now either way
never change cuz my Coopie got so much
to say that's so many thoughts in his
creative little brain not to say that
your brain is little I mean you know try
come up with a song on the spot while
you're exercising and losing light this
skill I'm gonna have to help Michael
Mann appreciate all your love and
support keep killing the game over on
your channel and we will catch you on
the next video